duke begins tout le monde ici va
participer à six jeux différents durant
les six jours à venir
photo cissé présent rivés sur le fil du
rasoir avec des dettes que vous ne
pourrez jamais rembourser celui ou celle
qui sortira vainqueur des six jeunes
remportera une énorme somme d'argent
à juste titre
oui doit à philémon tuer des gens comme
ça
je vous rappelle que participer à ce jeu
est d'une chance
à quel jour va jouer
tous les jeux auxquels ils nous ont fait
participer je les connais par coeur j'y
jouais quand j'étais petit les jeux
d'enfants des règles simples
on est on en fait quoi tient des
règlements faire
je te rappelle juste qu'on va devoir
tuer tout le monde ici
pour partir avec la récompense
[Musique]
nous avons nos marques couvertes de sang
vous allez continuer à ce que vous vivez
dans cette folie tout ça pour de
l'argent
c'est d'être un peu honnête tu veux pas
d'une femme d'un vieil homme comme
partenaire je dois absolument restaurant
sortir de cette ornière
[Musique]